Iran is warning the u.s. not to retake a
seized super tanker released overnight
Gibraltar rejected an American appeal to
detain the Iranian vessel longer it is
allegedly carrying sanctioned crude oil
and heading towards Greece in TST of is
in Tehran with a look at the impact of
international sanctions on Iran MTS good
morning good morning Iran is still
holding on to her British oil tanker and
is apparently trying to get around US
sanctions now in his first ever
interview with an American TV network a
top member of iran's elite Revolutionary
Guard bluntly criticized US actions it
swamp fish and death Hussein Dakin says
the u.s. is behaving like pirates and
called President Trump a gangster tough
talk from Iran's powerful Revolutionary
Guard
but there's another sanctions battle
being fought in Iran this time at a
Children's Hospital where it's every
parent's worst nightmare learning your
child's cancer has come back adding to
the agony the cocktail of drugs four
year old Maddie needs to stay alive
simply isn't available his mom tells me
Maddie is her only child but most
doctors can do for him now is keep him
comfortable Iran produces most of its
own pharmaceuticals but when it comes to
the most advanced medicines it relies
heavily on imports and that's how
sanctions can have an effect
technically medicines are exempt from US
sanctions but the financial transactions
to purchase them on the global
marketplace are not imports have dropped
by 80% are people losing their lives
because they can't get this drug
what do you say to a parent whose child
has cancer that the drug is available
outside of Iran but you can't bring it
into Iran what do you say to them I just
send them to pray and be sure that we
are with you we know your pain doctors
don't know exactly how many children
have died because of this inability to
bring in medicine but as the CEO of the
charity told us with 80 percent fewer
drugs coming in you only have to do the
math and mts tyub in Iran thanks